saint quentin en yvelines une terre de
vélo qui accueillera en 2024 le vélo sur
route sur piste le bmx et le vtt la
semaine olympique était l'occasion de
faire découvrir aux jeunes ces
disciplines à commencer par le bmx au
vélodrome nationale c'est une activité
qui est peu connu mais qu'on a la chance
d'avoir vraiment à proximité sur la
territoire c'est une activité nouvelle à
sensations fortes que les élèves aiment
beaucoup donc c'est génial pour eux de
la pouvoir l'expérimenté aujourd'hui une
initiation encadrée par un invité de
marque romain racines deuxième de la
dernière coupe du monde de bmx en élite
c'est un plaisir de pouvoir partager mon
expérience avec eux et également avec
les jeunes de la hesse qui encadrent eux
aussi leur but c'est de le faire dès que
découvrir en fait toute la piste et
qu'il
prenne plaisir en fait à découvrir le
site deux jours plus tard vendredi 28
janvier c'était au tour du futur site
d'accueil du vtt la colline d'elancourt
d'accueillir des classes au programme
pas de vélo mais un parcours de 5 km sur
la thématique environnementale
sur ce parcours il y avait plusieurs
panneaux un d'informations qui étaient
disposés donc les élèves s'arrêter à
chaque panneau découvrez les
informations qui étaient affichés et
emplissaient un petit quizz sur chaque
point il avait des questions alors sur
la faune et la flore sur l'aménagement
du site sur les épreuves olympiques est
donc arrivé en haut de la colline on
vérifier qu'il est bien remplie le quiz
et et on leur offrait un petit goûter on
nous a expliqué le petit parcours avec
les élèves retournent et les anneaux
répondre à des questions il avait un
petit livret à remplir au fur et à
mesure c'était très sportif j'ai une
classe qui bouge pas mal autre épreuve
de paris 2024 le golf a lui aussi été
mise à l'honneur pendant la semaine au
golf national de saint quentin en hippie
[Applaudissements]